we have never seen the river dry at this
time of the year there's not much grass
and is no enough what a state a foreign
world
the water is underground and this is how
we get water for both whirling powerless
stuff and also for people is how we are
the way go I'm in the morning before the
last of our list and see where the lands
are then we bring that message back to
the community so that they can avoid
those a so we just got a signal of Nanna
Matt will go around see if he's still
there
go back to the left we know the landside
in the area we go back and spread that
awareness within the community to that
we're more vigilant you go to Dallas
turn properly someone of just call us
and say that we had the gun shot - we're
just going in there and ship to see if
people are shooting that house I've just
come to land habitat and the lands are
very scared the lands are scared of the
cows because of people you know that we
came because people kill them
when Lance moved to a different place
alas I risk
you know win it
well the no one so we found out that
when they let's talk while taking water
drinking water on our well then the
elephant came there so people are
shooting up on the air to scare their
hands away
we have lived centuries with well life
anytime I lose a lamb it's just like
losing one of my family
there is no Lance in something it's no
life